الخسائر في صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي بشكل
غير مسبوق اليوم جبهات القتال اشتعلت من
جباليا شمالا وصولا الى خانيونس جنوبا
نحلل كل هذا مع اللواء فيس دويري الخبير
العسكري واستراتيجي مرحبا بك اللواء دويري
عبد القادر اطلعنا على نقاط الاشتباك
لاسما في الجنوب وكان لافتا ما نشره اليوم
ما نشرته كتائب القسام عن هذه الاشتباكات
التي حصلت في الجنوب والاستهداف المباشره
للجنود والافراد نعم جلال ولعلنا ربما هذا
الزخم الاخباري اليوم المتعلق بالاعلانات
اعلانات المقاومه المتعلقه باشتباكات على
كثير من الاصعده ولعلنا ننطلق بالاساس
بالحديث عن هذه الجبهات نحن نشير بالاساس
الى الاشتباكات في مناطق الشمال وتحديدا
الشجاعيه و جباليه ونتحدث عن جبهه خان
يونس في الجنوب كان هناك حديث عن كمائن عن
تدمير دبابات
بشكل كلي او جزئي عن استهداف اليات عسكريه
مختلفه لكن لو ذهبنا الى تفاصيل المشهد
وننطلق من الجبهه الجنوبيه وتحديدا من خان
يونس حينما نقول خان يونس نذكر بانها
تعرضت الى عمليه توغل اسرائيلي وذلك منذ
ايام عديده في محاوله نوع ما للوصول الى
وسطها وايضا محاوله ايضا تطويقها حتى من
الجهه
الغربيه الاخبار تتح دث على ان اخر
الاخبار مراسلنا تحدث عن دوي انفجارات
وايضا واشتباكات في وسط خان يونس تابعنا
فيديو لكتائب القسام نشرته الجزيره عن
عمليات التحام لكتائب القسام مع الجنود
الاسرائيليين وتبين من خلال مطابقه الصور
باننا نتحدث ربما عن المناطق الشرقيه لخان
يونس تحديدا في هذه المناطق الشرقيه وهي
وهي تقريبا كانت مواقع على الاشتباك
الاولى اضافه الى بعض المواقع في وسط خان
يونس ياتي ذلك بعد ان كانت كتائب القسام
قد اعلنت عن استهدافها
لقوات لقوات متمركزه هنا في في في شرق خان
يونس بقذائف الياسين ايضا كان هناك حديث
لسرايا القدس عن استهداف دبابات من نوع
الميركافا في هذه المواقع ولكن ايضا في
مواقع غرب خان يونس تحديدا في منطقه
المحطه اذا جبهه خان يونس جبهه مشتعله
تحدث ياتي ذلك بينما تحدث ابو عبيده
الناطق الرسمي باسم كتائب القسام عن نحو
44 او 44 اليه عسكريه تم تدميرها بشكل كلي
او جزئي خلال 48 ساعه وقتل نحو 40 جنديا
طبعا على مختلف الجبهات وحينما نقول على
مختلف الجبهات ننتقل الى الجبهه الشماليه
والجبهه الشماليه قد نبداها بالحديث عن
الشجاعيه الشجاعيه التي تعرضت الى عمليه
قصف اسرائيلي مكثفه وتحديدا حي الشجاعيه
وحي التفاح لكن بالمقابل كتائب القسام
اعلنت عن استهداف خمس مركبات خمس دبابات
من نوع ميركافا وايضا ثلاث جرافات وايضا
ناقله جون في هذا الموقع لو ذهبنا الى وسط
غزه حتى وسط غزه يعيش اشتباكات حيث القسام
ايضا اعلنت عن استهداف دبابات واليات
عسكريه اسرائيليه تحديدا في شارع الجلاء
اشتباكات ايضا هنا في حي الشيخ رضوان اذا
كما نلاحظ الشجاعيه وايضا وسط غزه والشيخ
رضوان يعيش على وقع اشتباكات الاشتباكات
الاخرى اللافته والتي تحدثت عنها القسام
كانت تحديدا في هذه المناطق في مخيم
جباليه في جباليه وفي الفلوجه من خلال
استهداف مركبات عسكريه ولكن ايضا وهذا هو
اللافت هذه ال الكمائن التي يتم نصبها
لجنود اسرائيليين كان هناك كمين هنا في
جباليا غرب جباليا تحديدا وكان هناك كمين
اخر لجنود في في احد المنازل في مخيم
جباليه حتى سرايا القدس تحدثت ايضا عن
استهداف ايضا استهداف مجموعه او من
العناصر من جنود اسرائيليين في محور بيت
لهيه اذا تطورات اخرى لافته في هذا المحور
الشمالي اذا الجبهه الشماليه تتحرك رغم
اننا في اليوم ال 6 من الحرب هذه التطورات
تاتي ايضا ربما في ظل ايضا عمليه القصف
المتواصله
لمخيم النصيرات والبريج والمغازي وكان
هناك تابعنا ايضا الحديث عن مجزره ارتكبت
في المغازي هناك منزل سقط فيه تقريبا 13
شهيدا وذلك في عاجل نقلناه على الجزيره
اذا كل مناطق غزه شمالا وفي الوسط وفي
الجنوب تعيش على وقع الاشتباكات ولكن على
وقع عمليه القصف المتواصله ونختم بالحديث
ايضا عن عمليات القصف التي ظلت تطال ايضا
مناطق غلاف غزه كيسوفيم وايضا القاعده
العسكريه في رعيم مما يدل على ان صواريخ
المقاومه لازالت تصل الى هذه المواقع
وربما الرقم اللافت هو ما اشار الى انه
تقريبا منذ بدايه الحرب 2000 2000 عمليه
انذار بسقوط صواريخ على غلاف غزه وهذا رقم
كبير طبعا جلال تطورت على اكثر من صعيد
نختمها بما قاله ابو عبيده فيما يتعلق
بوجود الاف من المقاتلين والمقاومين لم
يدخلوا بعد الحرب ولعله امر لافت اضافه
الى ما يحدث في شمال وجنوب غزه ومن الجنوب
ابدا مع اللواء فيز ويري بعد ان نشرت
كتائب القسام اللواء الدويري هذا الفيديو
الذي يبرز التحام مباشر بين الفصائل
الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال في خانيونس
التي وضعها الاحتلال هدفا اساسيا في
عمليته البريه جنوبا ماذا قرات في هذه
الصور التي نشرت اليوم يعني هذا الفيديو
الاول الذي ياتي من منطقه خانيونس
وقلنا
و وضحنا الصعوبه في اعداد هذه الافلام
قياسا مع منطقه غزه لماذا بسبب طبيعه
المنطقه في غزه المجال متاح اتحدث عن
مدينه غز القاطع الشمالي يخرج المقاتل من
النفق يجد مكان امن ضمن عده خطوات او
عشرات الامتار يتخذ مكانه وبالتالي يتم
اعداد تصوير العمليه باريحيه نسبيه لكن في
هذه المنطقه لا الوضع مختلف لماذا لماذا
لانه طبيعه الاسقاط الديموغرافي على
الجغرافيا مختلفه اذا نظرنا الى شرق صلاح
الدين بن سهيلا وغيرها
عبسان الجديده
وعبس الكبرى
والصغرى القراره نجد هناك مسافات بينيه ما
بين المنازل وبالتالي شبكه الانفاق لها
مخارج متعدده في اماكن متعدده عندما يخرج
المقاتل سيكون مكشوفا في معظم الحالات وقد
يكون الهدف ابعد من المسافه الصفريه وعليه
ان يتقرب من الهدف وبالتالي هو مكشوف يبحث
عن ممر امن اولويته الاولى ان يصل الى
نقطه امنه تؤمن له المسافه الصفريه يطلق
القذيفه ومن ثم عليه ان ينسحب قبل ان يتم
اقتناصه فتكون فرصه اعداد الفيلم فيها
صعوبه لهذا السبب هذا الفيلم اذا لاحظناه
رغم جودته في بعض اللقطات في لقطات اخرى
لا دون الجوده التي تقدم في الشمال بسبب
صعوبه الظروف لكن رغم ذلك جاء الفيديو
والفيديو كان متعدد الجوانب هناك استخدام
لياسين سواء مباشر من القاذف او من
الطائره مسيره او المسيره طائرات الدرون
كذلك
استخدام التي بي جي وااي والتي بي بي اللي
هي ضد الافراد ومن مسافات قريبه جدا
واستهداف دبابات استهداف جنود داخل
المباني واللقطه الاولى كانت ست جنود
يتحركوا اختفوا خلف ساتر تم استهدافهم سقط
واحد احدهم مباشره فكان صوره معبره مصغره
عما يجري في هذه المنطقه وبالتالي توقعاتي
من متابعتي وكمحاولة
ما جرى فيها حتى الان هو مقدمه لكتاب وليس
وليس صفحات الكتاب الحقيقيه الصفحات
الحقيقيه كمحلل اقول انها ستظهر في الايام
القادمه ا ما ما مدى
صعوبه هذه العمليات
اطلاق الياسين بهذه
الطريقه من ثم الاصابه المباشره كما نتابع
الان اللواء فيز الدويري من قبل كتائب
القسام وفي ظل هذه الظروف التي يعيشها
القطاع برمته عودنا
اي عودتنا كتائب القسام ان تاتينا
بمفاجئات في في في في خطواتها لانها تفكر
خارج الصندوق الاعتيادي للفكر العسكري
وكفاءه المقاتلين فوق طاقه البشر العاديه
او الجنود العاديين لهذا السبب تكاتف هذ
هذه الشقي المعادله يقدم لنا امور تكون في
بعض الحالات خارج اطار التوقع رغم كل
الظروف الصعبه رغم تباين الامكانات تباين
القدرات لكن يقدم لنا اثباتات فيما
بالجانب المقابل جيش الاحتلال كل القدرات
المتاحه المسخره له كجيش يعتبر رقم 18
عالميا جسر جوي مفتوح من قبل حلفائه ويقدم
اعلام
سطحيا قدم ثلاثه افلام بعد متابعتي لها
ومحاوله قراءتها اجد انها لا تستحق
الاهتمام لانها لم لم
تجسد صوره معركه طيب هذه فيديو اخر نشرته
كتائب القسام لاستهداف هذه هذه ميركافا
صحيح مكافه في تل الزع مكافه اربعه هذه
الميركافا اربعه لانها تحمل المظله
الخارجيه العلويه هنا واضح الاستهداف
المباشر ايضا نعم الان لماذا انا اقتنع ب
واصدق ما يصدر عن القسام ه هذه اللقطه هي
تمثل حقيقه المعركه هناك هدف وهناك
استهداف وبالتالي نشاهد اثر الاستهداف على
الهدف فيما في الافلام التي قدمها جيش
الاحتلال تمثل جانب واحد من المعادله لم
ارى في الثلاثه افلام اي جندي اي مقاتل
اخر مقابله لم اسمع صوت اي سلاح غير
البصمه الو
الخاصه بالعد لدي سؤال هنا تبدو هنا منطقه
ضيقه هل هذا طبيعي بان يعني تتواجد دباب
نعم نعم هي ه هذه المساحات الموجوده ام
يعني لا يوجد شوارع اوتوستراد
بسته ممرات في كل جانب انت ت تاخذ ثلاثه
شوارع رئيسيه شارع الكرامه وشارع صلاح
الدين وشارع الرشيد والشوارع العرضيه شارع
عمر المختار شارع رقم ثمانيه شارع 10 اذا
هناك شوارع محدده وماعد ذلك ازقه دقه يعني
ما هو طبيعه البناء في مخيم جباليا في
الفيلم الذي عرضه الجيش الاحتلال اسقه لا
تتجاوز متر او متر ونص كان يتحرك فيها
الجنود اذا اذا كان هناك مساحه سته الى
سبعه امتار تدخل هذه الدبابه لانها ترغب
بالوصول الى هدف ما فعندما تعلق في هذه
النقطه تصبح هدفا سهلا شكرا لك اللواء
فيزير الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
التغطيه دائما مستمره نعود اليك لمتابعتها